make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are picking up with x-men
issue number two yes Don of X how do I
love Don of X okay here's a funny thing
about this right this story picks up
with Cyclops walking in to greet his
children Rachel summers and cable now
this is gonna this is gonna blow your
mind just to give you some history on
the complex nature of these characters
right just just to show you how
ridiculously complex the x-men has been
over the years here's the origin of
these two kids right see if you can see
if you can follow this I want to see if
you can follow this so Rachel summers
isn't even from this universe Rachel
summers is from an alternate reality
which you guys know as Days of Future
past and in this alternate reality
Cyclops and Jean Grey had a child but it
turned out to be Rachel as most of you
guys know the the assassination of
Senator Robert Kelley more McTaggart and
Charles Xavier jump-started the simple
program and signals became essentially
self-aware and then conquered North
America as a result of that Rachel
summers alongside Franklin Richards
Kitty Pryde magneto Colossus and
Wolverine and I think storm basically
orchestrated an escape that allowed
Rachel summers to use her powers and
send the mine of Kitty Pryde into the
past
Kitty Pryde went back she stopped the
events of Days of Future Passed from
happening which made the Days of Future
past reality in alternate universe as a
result to that because it didn't change
Rachel summers not knowing that it was
now an alternate universe basically went
to the past and then skipped over to the
main male universe where she's been ever
since so that's the origin of her
character cable just the origin of cable
it's an absolute mess okay so one bit
after Jean Grey died during the events
of the Dark Phoenix saga you ended up
learning that she was basically cloned
by mr. sinister and this clones name was
Madeleine Pryor and this was done
because of the fact that sinister
believed that if Jean Grey and Cyclops
ever had a child that child would be
insanely powerful because of the genes
of these two characters and so
eventually he Sims Madeleine Pryor out
into the world Madeleine Pryor ends up
meeting a cyclops at a family reunion
the two of them hit it off they start
knocking boots nine months later she's
given birth to a kid Cyclops abandoned
him he actually ended up taken on taking
off on him because Jean Grey came back
and so he abandoned his wife in his and
his and his unborn child at the time the
result is that eventually Madeleine
Pryor gave birth to Nathan summers and
because of that the villain apocalypse
realizing how powerful cable could be
kidnapped him and then infected him with
a techno-organic virus so that if cable
was able to over comment that he would
prove himself being you know
himself to be worthy cyclops gathered
together the Inhumans x-force in the
x-men they battle apocalypse they
basically managed to push him away and
then Rachel Summers who had jumped to
the future had basically become a member
of a group called a clan Toscani who was
opposed to apocalypse and basically said
give us your baby and that will take him
to the future and we will essentially
try to try to cure him if we can't and
will clone him what we'll do the next
best thing and so as a result of that
they took baby Nathan to the Future in
the year 4000 ad they were not able to
cure him so they ended up cloning him
apocalypse broke in realizing that
Nathan Summers was now in the future
that he ruled and the result was that
they ended up kidnapping the clone
instead of the actual baby Nathan and so
baby Nathan grew up to become the
character of cable who basically hung
out with clan Toscani and then the clone
ended up hanging out with apocalypse and
his name was strife that's the origin of
cable that's how ridiculous the x-men
have been over the years right these two
characters were these insanely complex
histories or just hanging out with
Cyclops I thought you guys might find
that interesting but the funny thing
about this is that what's going on here
is there is a massive island that
basically popped up about a hundred
miles off the coast of kokoa and the
question is what's going on with this
with this island right like why is it
there as well as a result of that
Cyclops is basically gathering Rachel
summers and cable in order to do a recon
mission now here's the thing this is an
insanely powerful team that's one of
these understand here they're insanely
powerful right like cable is an
omega-level mutant albeit that cable
isn't really as powerful as he could be
because he has to use his celebrity in
telekinesis to keep the techno-organic
virus from consuming its body Rachel
summers is an Omega level telepath right
like she's insanely powerful and so
you're talking about two of the most
powerful mutants on the face of the
planet who are just going to do a recon
mission imagine what it's like to be a
dad like hey well I'd like you guys to
meet my son cable and my daughter Rachel
they're two of the most powerful mutants
on the face of the planet ah you know
just don't mess with them otherwise you
know they'll basically make you think
that you're a dog and you're gonna spend
the rest of your days barking at people
and probably locked in a mental
institution
it's kind of medicine but when they get
to this island this this ion itself
really kind of houses like this massive
you know sort of organism this seems to
be coming from the volcanic structure
and so when they immediately get out
there and they immediately start looking
around the question they really have to
ask here is what's the purpose behind
this like like what is this thing their
cool thing about this is that as they
make their way through they start to
find these
of life but they're more herbivores than
anything else where they felt like a
giant cow and and so on so forth so
there's nothing at the knee real threat
here until it's consumed by like this
giant snake looking thing that leads to
like all three of these guys basically
like annihilating it right you know
Cyclops using his optic beams and Rachel
summers using her telepathy and
telekinesis and a cable firing off as
big guns but what it does is it
basically jumps over to this all-white
character this character that actually
looks really really cool crying like
black tears essentially and then
conversing with some individual that we
can't see that's either inside of like
another portal or something along those
lines but on the side of something else
and he keeps addressing it his mother
but the idea is at most you know the the
mother of this guy is is really telling
I'm like what's going on here like these
these islands are merging together what
you have to do is you have to find him
you have to locate him he's the one that
will lead you and he's the one that will
basically save everything that's always
really sort of a weird thing because
what we end up learning is this kid is
what's called a summoner now here's the
funny thing about this this is like
Skyrim basically right you have like a
summoner Minor and you've got a summoner
adept and you've got a high summoner in
the sense that like a summoner Minor can
can summon like lower things you know
familiars and so on and so forth and
then as you get higher and level they
can summon more and greater things
because that's what that's when the
situation sort of begins to pop off
right because when it comes to the
character of cable cable is very much
one of those shoot force shoot first ask
questions later kind of guys right it's
just kind of like alright let's just
sort of get to it and and go from there
now when this all-white guy basically
this summoner shows up here it's
speaking in a language that none of them
understand and the funny thing is that
in reality they probably could have
grabbed Doug lamzy they probably
could've grabbed cypher but as we know
from the New Mutants story ciphers all
the way out in Shiar space this is the
reason why we're covering each one of
these stories individually right because
they all tie in and what the other one
is doing or they're all telling their
own stories plus it's really cool and
cohesive where you could just kind of do
them all individually and sort of call
it a day the real question becomes what
happens when they all start branching
off and doing their own thing and it
becomes this unruly mess which it
inevitably will because it's you know
comic books it's the nature of what they
do but this first but they can't really
understand the language of this guy and
it's sort of cool because this guy does
a come here as a villain it's not as
though he's he's kind of like a bad guy
who wants to tear things up or rip
things apart and that wasn't that was
initially almost kind of the way that
hitman played it was like this is a bad
guy this is one of the things to
understand about Jonathan Hickman is
that with this guy being a summoner well
he's not overly powerful at the moment
the idea is
someone'll online he probably will be
that's the way Hickman does things right
this character showing up here is going
to become insanely important later on
down the line most likely orc is likely
going to join the roster of the x-men
most like this that's what's going to be
the case but regardless Cable in his
infinite wisdom decides to hand off a
gift to this guy
and this gift comes in the form of a
grenade and it's kind of crazy here
because it's like you know I wanted to
give him a gift I want to show that we
don't mean any harm so I gave him a
thermal grenade and of course like this
guy presses the button and like
detonates the grenade and so of course
that progress is exactly what we would
think it would when it's kind of like
you tried to kill me right so like he
immediately starts to lose his mind not
really loses his mind but basically
starts so many are using his abilities
as a summoner and starts like Bruno
introducing like these these gigantic
monsters now the idea behind this is
that they're able to see he's able to
summon beings or summon monsters from
what's called Otherworld or outer world
and the reason why that matters is
because it's very very much akin to like
a scar like we've talked about that
before that in in every universe in
Marvel Comics you have what are called
pocket dimensions and these are
dimensions that are astronomically small
right in the sense that like they're not
as big as universes there's just really
small spaces that you can't just walk to
you usually have to pass some kind of
dimensional barrier or have a portal
open in the case of Asgard the Bifrost
is open which is basically a portal that
allows you to access access Asgard but
this place Otherworld is the exact same
way the difference is that other world
exists outside of the multiverse right
it's not confined to a singular universe
but the principle still remains the same
and the overall gist here is that what
you end up having is this summoner
basically bringing peace from what
Jonathan Hickman describes as the lands
beyond Otherworld essentially like the
wildlands and the reason why this
matters is because Otherworld itself is
a giant landmass right there's different
areas that are there but you have King
Arthur's Camelot and so on and so forth
but a lot of the areas outside of that
are unexplored or unexplained by Marvel
so we don't really know what's there and
it's one of those things where he was
just kind of saying like if there's wild
stuff out there and basically this
summoner can bring those things to this
location and then use them for whatever
it is that he wants to achieve
why is like these wild and fantastic
beasts from out there so the reality is
that he's not summoning them from places
that were familiar with he's just
somebody get from way out in other walls
they're just kind of crazy beasts and
monsters and so on and so forth so in
the middle of this great big huge fight
Rachel summers ends up using her
telepathy and what she does is
communicate with this guy directly and
of course that's when
thing ceases and the question is why did
you try to destroy me it's like well I
didn't mean destroy you like I meant to
give you a gift and you know I just kind
of wanted to show you that like hey
we're we're good guys here like we're
not really bad guys which is a pretty
important message to communicate right
like hey like please don't kill us we're
just here to be cool like we don't want
to cause problems or anything like that
and so it's kind of funny because the
question is asked by Scott Summers
why is your island coming over at our
island and that's when we really kind of
harken back to the events of house and
powers of X and this is a rock oh that's
what this island is if you guys remember
back during the housing powers of X the
krikawa where's originally one giant
landmass so you had arauco which was one
island can you actor chroma which is the
other and because of the fact that these
kind of demons or monsters were sort of
rising up from the rift in between these
two places that with the scheming of
apocalypse and using his four horsemen
that ultimately these monsters and
demons were suppressed and the island
was essentially split and so those
Horsemen of apocalypse would stay on
arauco and ensure those monsters and
demons would never show up again and and
that was kind of like the role they
would play there was sort of the Hidden
Horseman that we didn't really know
about and so what this does is basically
say that like this island is not
returned that kurková is not a fully is
not a fully cohesive unit and it's
basically merged itself with arauco it's
back to its back to its normal self but
because of the fact that all this is
based on the fact that these islands
were split what it does is go exactly
where you're expected to in the sense
that you've got this guy just kind of
out there doing his own thing and sort
of analyzing this new location that he's
in have they never seen the surface
world before and he's met by the arrival
of apocalypse apocalypse basically
speaks the exact same language as you
know and understand exactly what he's
saying and it's like you know I had
never met you before like who is your
mother like like who was that they gave
birth to you to which he replies I was
born by war I was born by the horseman
war as it was cool because what it means
now is the horseman of procreating
either kind of keeping themselves going
and propagating and and so on and so
forth and so ultimately it's really
Hickling how to setting the stage for
what comes next insofar as this guy
basically says the forces that the
horsemen were sent to keep contained are
returning they're coming back and so
we're going to have to like marshal
forces or what have you in order to save
these guys off now keep in mind this was
not an easy fight for apocalypse to win
apocalypse and his horsemen had to work
in unison and put on one heck of a fight
in order to achieve this reason why I
say that matters and the reason why it
is it's so cool here is because knowing
Jonathan Hickman there'll be a pretty
significant battle that will take place
and what it does we'll get to see the
full toad
Halliday of apocalypses powers put on
display which I am very excited about
but without being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come this explain make sure
you guys at the sub button to become
part of the world for if you guys enjoy
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]